So what I'm now going to do is--I'm going to take the structure here, make it a bit smaller like this
and take away the NP here, and we are going to reappear in a minute.
What I'm now going to do is I'm going to put a bunch of these structures together.
So connect this one edge, connect this one edge, and we're also going to do one here
and now call this one A and this one B.
Now, what you see here is that I have taken three structures like these
and put them between A and B.
I'm going to do this more generally now.
Imagine that instead of an edge here, I could have more of these structures.
I'll just write three dots here and these will represent
additional copies of this structure being in between here.
So in total, I will have n copies of the structure--n times this structure here appears between A and B.
And now my question is, how many shortest paths between A and B
can you have that visit all of the vertices here.
If you have n copies of that structure, is that n², is that 2^n, or is that 2n.